Deadpool two hits theaters this Friday
we've got your review right here on
screen junkies I'm Dan Burke and I'm
Roth Cornett and this is one of the most
anticipated sequels of the summer season
would you agree Dan I would very much
agree it's it's weird that in a weird
way because of Avengers infinity war
moving up a week Deadpool 2 kind of
kicks off the official summer season
although infinity we're kind of did it
just moved back a week but yeah this is
like the one of the first big summer
popcorn movies to come out and I think
that fans of Deadpool are not going to
be disappointed in this movie absolutely
this is a rare sequel and a very rare as
you pointed out earlier today a rare
comedy sequel that not only is able to
meet the expectations of the original
but also expand on the world that was
created in the characters that were
created give them surprisingly a little
bit more depth while still keeping him
the same smart ass smart aleck a
fourth-wall breaking commentary on comic
book genre movies character that we know
and love in Deadpool yeah my hats are
off to Ryan Reynolds and the creative
team behind this movie because you're
right
they're able to tell a story that
actually has some heart to it like there
are character beats you know and we get
to the third act of this movie and I
realize like I care about these
characters I care about what happens to
them I'm invested in what's going on
which it would be very easy to not do
that
simultaneously I think it is just as
funny as the first one and I love that
it is embraced its role this franchise
in particular has embraced its role as
the smart alec in the front row
not just for x-men films and not just
for Marvel films there are shots at
every franchise at every movie in the
comic book genre and I love that they
are able to balance that it's not just a
fourth-wall breaking self-referential
thing and it's not just a comic book
kind of big action movie they've melded
both of them and I think they did it
successfully and hilarious I agree and
the other thing that's interesting is we
need that now right because we have this
is such a dominant genre right now so
that he's sort of able to speak the
words that many of us are thinking even
about the
films that we love and what's
interesting you mentioned infinity war
is one of the things that I said about
infinity war and we've said is that it's
sort of the perfect version of what that
movie needed to be right Deadpool 2 is
the perfect version of what this movie
needed to be and they are diametrically
opposed in many ways even though
Deadpool is sort of the answer to
infinity war because the stakes remain
as they did in the first movie very very
personal yeah these aren't it's not
about saving the universe or the world
it is about something that is incredibly
heartfelt and personal to that character
so as much as he's Illaria s-- i felt
actually emotionally moved one or two
moments surprisingly yeah and I'm sure
all the other franchises are kind of
shaking their fist because what this
movie can also do is put the tropes of
the genre in their movie oh yeah but
comment on it and then twist it in such
a way that you don't mind that they're
doing something that's been seen before
because a the stuff that's in there that
is the action david leitch the direction
I think which a lot of people were
concerned about because you know you
lost your original director I thought
the action was really well staged
they're able to comment at one point
about a particular sequence and how
cinematic it shouldn't be it actually is
so I think that the action is well
staged and they again they do it in a
way that is I think cool but also that
is in itself a commentary on the action
and other comic book movies which is
interesting and there's a joke made
about that to you about CGI action
sequence they're really yeah there is
and so I'm sure that there are a lot of
writers and directors out there for the
other franchises that are like why do
they get to do that we just have to do
it straight-faced and they get to make
fun of it that pool got to it first too
bad but but it's not just that
commentary you have to make it cool in
and of itself which I think they do and
it's what you want a sequel to do which
is to embrace what people liked in the
first movie to fold in some new elements
at the same time and then to try to
deliver something that is both an
avocation and a build building block
above the first movies and I think that
this that's what this movie does it does
that very
successfully you know it's got a little
bit more money on it and I think they
use that money very wisely because to
your point the action sequences are
impressive in and of themselves but more
importantly they are driven by the story
and they are driven by character and
that's I think a lot of times when we
lose interest in action sequences is
when they're not motivated right these
are a hundred percent motivated by who
these characters are about what they're
by their abilities their personalities
and what the story is is trying to
communicate there's some new characters
here it surprisingly sets up a future
without feeling ham-fisted
it does and it's a family film it's
being marketed as a family film the same
way the first one was a valentine's film
it's it's a twisted family film broken
little family it is a broken family but
I you know I liked the new characters I
Domino I think is a standout oh yeah I
thought that I liked Josh Brolin as
cable now the character in this movie is
kind of a function of the plot in many
ways there's not a whole lot of
character growth beyond you get some
background info but he is kind of there
more as an inciting incident so you know
I don't think there's a lot to the
character of cable hopefully they're
gonna fill that in later but I thought
he was good as the character again he is
a badass in a movie where they comment
on how much of a badass he is or isn't
there are some surprise cameos some
extended cameos one particular very
quick surprise cameo that I thought was
just amazingly hilarious and kudos to
everyone for doing that because it would
have been easy I think to kind of fold
your arms and say like I'm not going to
do that and then to do that I thought
was great I thought it was kind of a
nice stroke of genius I think you're
right in the sense that the thing that
works about Deadpool in these
performances they're all really strong
but right those are the standouts
because Josh Brolin is so committed to
who that character is while Ryan
Reynolds is so committed to his
character and one is aware of the movie
that he's in and one is it what is it
and so it's played really perfectly very
surprisingly well-balanced look I didn't
believe when they said this is a
valentine's movie that it was but it was
a great Valentine's movie it really was
and this one actually is kind of a
hilarious
hard-r that's very hard art yes but
surprisingly heartfelt family films that
is still don't let that kind of twist
you it's everything that you want
Deadpool to be if you like the first
movie you're gonna like this one
and it's not a perfect movie there are
very few that are and and I felt with
this one much like I felt with the first
one which is that they're throwing a lot
of jokes atcha and when you throw that
many jokes that just some are gonna miss
and some are gonna hit and just like the
first one I think there's some misses or
I just kind of like you either kind of
go like yeah or they fall a little flat
but the ones that hit hit so hard and
some of them are timed and executed so
well again just like any comedy it kind
of makes up for the ones that don't hit
so you know I think probably how much
you enjoy this movie and how much you
get and appreciate some of the humor
depends on how much you're invested in
the genre how much you know about the
characters how much you know about Ryan
Reynolds how much you know about pop
culture you know but there's also some
that are great physical gags there are
some great there's one particular that's
really funny and again takes a joke from
the first movie and builds on it expands
on it and takes it to somewhere new
that I think you know you could have
just done the same joke again but they
kind of gave it a twist and did in a
really inventive way and then again
because it's Deadpool they're able to do
things in the end game of the movie
right before you leave the theater that
any other movie could not do but it
doesn't and it is hysterically funny any
other movie it would be betrayal of what
you've just watched but Deadpool it
works perfectly and it does set you up
and leave you hungry for more so again
you're right nothing is perfect
certainly this isn't and this isn't
necessarily aiming to be an Oscar movie
no even though they may joke differently
yeah it's not anything to be an Oscar
movie that's not what this is about but
as far as fulfilling the promise of
doing everything it's set out to do as a
Deadpool sequel I think it does it it
does it as well as it could have it's
very satisfying if you like that first
phone I think if you're a fan you should
go see it we're gonna talk a lot more in
depth on news on Saturday morning
Saturday morning we have a spoiler
review going up for Deadpool 2 we'll get
into see cuz they're gonna be some
things that people are gonna want to
talk
but I agree with you I'm a big fan of
the first deadpool movie for me this one
stands up there with the first one it'd
be a hilarious double feature and
looking forward to seeing it again
because they throw so many jokes and
there's so many little easter eggs and
things to look for
i think even on a second viewing it's
gonna be rich with just things to catch
and throw aways and visual stuff and
yeah i like this movie and i think
especially if you like the first
deadpool movie you're really gonna enjoy
this one too well I'm gonna look forward
to talking to you in more depth in our
spoiler review to be on screen junkies
news this Saturday morning this coming
Saturday morning yeah you can all talk
about it together exactly yeah
Deadpool 2 hits theaters on Friday
really Thursday night now but let's say
Friday because that's the date on the
poster yeah go see it come back here on
Saturday morning or actually over on
screen junkies news for a spoiler review
let us know what you thought of the
movie and we'll be able to break down
some of the fun cool surprises that this
movie has a store thank you Thank You
Ross and thank you for watching we're
always here reviewing the latest movies
the summers just getting going and we'll
be back very soon there's another this
is a little tiny movie coming up next
week that we might have a few words to
say about does it involve a war of stars
it might involve a war stars until then
you
[Music]